alright hey everybody we are at sticks
out podcast number 12 with Cassie
McKinney's hey Cassie how you doing I'm
good good to see you yeah it looks
really bright over there huh
yeah sunny in Mexico so why don't we get
a little bit of your your story who are
you where are you from originally
and how did you find yourself where
you're located now um I was born in
Baltimore Maryland and spent my first
twenty years and was really into live
music and like kinda lifestyle like
traveling around going to see bands
making jewelry by hand and selling it to
go see bands while ignoring my college
education basically and once I graduated
college
I don't know how I did that I'm sorry if
I switch into Spanish sometimes it's
kind of a fight in my brain right now
between English and Spanish but I moved
to Florida to be with some family after
I graduated college and there I
continued going to see live music and
found some hula hoopers so here we are
staring at a Mexican couch and it
appears that there is a towel on the
couch in case in addition it appears
they have yellow paint in Mexico in
addition clearly better lighting in my
house okay alright so you moved to
Florida don't happen continue team live
bands and through music was introduced
to looping and at first I thought it
looked really stupid and was like I
would never do that
who was actually super talented and
really engaging and fun to watch with
the Bulova so i asked her to start
teaching me and that was a great way to
build my friendship with her and start
being active in my body again which felt
really good but unfortunately she got a
little jealous of me practicing a lot I
just want to quit so to kind of change
that problem I picked up a second hoop
and started learning how to do things
with two hoops so that she couldn't
compare herself to me and she doesn't
actually hoop anymore but from two hoops
I went onto three hoops and then heard
of this place called the Vulcan in the
Bay Area immerse myself into spinning
and circus and surround myself with
people who were levels better than me to
inspire me to push me kind of break me
down to build me up kind of situation
and through living at the Vulcan and the
people that I met there and practice and
the dedication that I cultivated there I
sort of built my whole life around
circus and lubes now I live in Mexico
and I'm working people tend to take
circus more seriously here so there's
more opportunities to work and things
are a little bit more cheap here so I
can take that money that I make with
juggling and circus and still live and
still have time to train which I didn't
in the States so hooping is the main
prop we're the only prop you've ever
done yeah nine years now and I get
around a lot of poison turns a lot of
staff spinners around a lot of LA all
the props and I've never been called to
anything else like I've never I liked
watching other people do things and I
respect the time and the effort that it
takes I think it's beautiful but I've
just never been called to do anything
else
and I feel like there's so much to learn
with hula boobs that learning other
things obviously cross-training is
valuable but I felt like that was
detrimental it would take away from the
things that I wanted to accomplish into
things I wanted to learn with hoops so
you're in Mexico what's one of the
biggest differences about being in
America in Mexico in terms of Circus
flow and juggling and whatever else like
what are some differences that you
noticed in your first year right year
and a half get in there yeah been here
almost like a year in three months now I
think the biggest difference that I've
noticed not even just in the juggling
community just in people here in general
which transfers into the circus world
here is open and trusting to new people
here immediately they trust you and they
want to be your friend to people until
you show that you're trustworthy or
honest or whatever it is that they like
about you but here people are more open
more warm and I found that in the
juggling and spinning community here
that people are really really excited to
welcome new people in and there's less I
feel less kind of less competition less
of an edge here than I did in the States
is flowing juggling more integrated
they're in super separate no and so how
much is a juggling community so there's
this street by performing thing that is
a Latin America norm it seems in many
places is that seem like really
affiliated with the juggling and circus
scene or is that like a totally separate
thing is there like a professional like
how does that work I have only tried
it's a whole different it's a whole
different world I feel like because it's
illegal to do in the States it's such a
novel thing I feel like it's
think I would much rather see someone
performing at a street leg with juggling
balls or overlooking that and have
someone with the sign telling me their
life problems you know I know that's
kind of a dick thing to say but and I'd
rather give that person money and here
it's like accepted they see someone do
something and they give up some money
and you'll see people with the baby on
their back at the street by juggling
knives and it's just like it's cool it's
just kind of like another job but I
think it's not like a professional thing
it's something people do when they need
money and if they have a job where
they're gaining money other ways you
won't see them out of street light and
my biggest thing why I don't want to be
out of street light is because he's
sitting in the middle of car exhaust for
hours and hours and it's just not super
healthy and living here in Mexico City
it's like the pollution is crazy here
and so it's something like 15 cigarettes
the equivalent of smoking 15 cigarettes
a day just living here so see any good
light is just adding insult to injury at
that point but definitely it's it's
respected but it's not something you do
if you have another job you know so is
there like a history have you gotten
into any other history of circus in
Mexico I mean like do you know anything
about that is it go up a little bit
there's a company here called circus of
tiding and it's a family at I de a ta y
de ata y de and they've been doing shows
in Mexico it's a family circus and
they've been doing shows in Mexico since
the early 1900s I think maybe even
sooner I'm not sure the exact date but
at least since like 1910 I've seen
pictures of their shows and they had a
big tent in Mexico City up until like
two months ago they took down the tent
because they're moving to more seasonal
and like they have a youth circus that
they're traveling around Mexico and they
have a smaller tent where they're doing
more like seasons and less thing that's
there all the time and if the first time
they move that tent in like 70 years so
that's kind of a big thing but yeah it's
super traditional here it's really
respected it's part of the culture here
in Mexico and people in America when you
tell them you're a juggler you
in Cirque du Soleil or you juggle
chainsaws are the two references but I
get the most um but here it's like oh
you're your juggler cool and there's not
like that next question that shows you
that this person has zero frame of
reference of what you're talking about
or that they're grasping for some sort
of context they know and it's respected
okay cool
that's your job so ways you've been
joking you said eight years or playing
with hoops eight years yeah how did you
continually stay motivated to do hoops
like I'm just curious now cuz I think
I've seen you always with ah who are
plural I'm just curious like over the
past eight years why have you continued
to or is it like a older because it
seems now you're on this like just
hooping train when at times at least as
far as I've known you you've been a rock
ornament or or different sort of little
blips and you've also been a fitness
coach and like you know like at what
yeah how do you stay motivated to do all
this other people who were better than
me like I want to do what they're doing
and then kind of I started performing
and in that time I was super inspired by
him because he's an amazing juggler and
was teaching me leaps and balance on
daily basis as we were performing or
rehearsing for the flow show and I was
learning tricks just for the act it
wasn't like these are the tricks I know
this is the act I wanna make so I need
to learn these tricks which is kind of
backwards but that was really motivating
and he was a big motivating factor for
me really inspiring and really
encouraging
and then getting involved with the IJA
was kind of a huge factor and when we
first met each other I was really really
focused on my fitness career and getting
my certifications as a trainer and as a
nutrition coach and so my practice time
was going down a little bit and then I
moved to the same city as her and we
decided we wanted to work together and
that just like was an immediate rocket
up as far as hours practicing to your
perform preparing for IJA and for other
shows and we needed to put the time in
so that was a huge factor and now to be
honest I'm like I feel I'm performing a
lot but I'm not super motivated to
juggle right now just like I see other
people juggling and I love watching it
and I still love the heart but I don't
really feel a whole lot of like spark at
this moment for juggling I see that so
you're working on fitness goals instead
at this point yeah I'm working on my
business so what is the history of your
business what is this business you're
talking about yeah is my company and
it's a personal training and nutrition
coaching company and what I do is make
custom nutrition plans and custom
exercise programs for people's lifestyle
so instead of buying a premade exercise
package or a meal plan online I work
with my clients one-on-one with their
body goals with their experiences their
injuries their allergies dietary
restrictions whatever it is to get them
to where they want to be so what is the
why did you start that what's the reason
for that um I got really into my own
personal fitness I was smoking a ton of
weed at the time like way more weed than
any human being living in Oregon as a
[Music]
and so I was going to the gym
feeling good about my activity but I was
because I was smoking a ton I was eating
really bad and just like not paying
attention to my health in other ways
other than spending that hour in the gym
and I got frustrated with that so I
noticed that I was extremely addicted to
sugar that I had no self-control as far
as what I was eating and so I got really
focused in a 12-week period to reframe
my relationship with food and really
dial in my habits for my fitness and
through that I was inspired to share
with other people because people were
asking me questions wanting to know what
I was eating what I was doing and it's
something that a lot of people want to
do but aren't sure how to do it so it
feels really good to be able to share
that with people and it's really
rewarding the same feeling that I get
and got from teaching juggling and
spinning is really similar except for I
feel like it's more profound because
it's something that's allowing someone's
lunch it longevity to increase and
they're feeling happier in their body
and happier with themselves and all that
stuff can come from juggling and
spinning but it's more tangible with
fitness and what was your degree in
college for everybody journalism
journalism yeah I wanted to be a pretty
girl on the sidelines of the football
field I was in high school I was super
obsessed with sports football the NFL in
general and more specifically and wanted
to be like a sports journalist and I
changed I changed my major three years
in because I kind of opened my mind a
little bit don't really agree with that
at all but changed my major more towards
general journalism and communication and
got a job out of college working at an
art school that most of the kids there
were immigrant families so I was able to
use kind of my degree in communication
and international communication with
those families and that's how I kind of
linked my education to what I was doing
but now I'm not really doing anything
with my college degree except for
I'm dead right so do you think you'll be
in Mexico for the long term you were you
in suspect I really like it here I I
want to stay I need to figure out how to
do that exactly make everything super
legit to stay here but I really like it
here
I have a dog I have an apartment I live
here with McKenzie and she's really
happy here also and it feels good okay
and so you're coming back to the state's
this year for said kinetic fire is that
true Thank You FG and equilibrium the
three of us all be in the states this
year and so okay here's a good question
so used to get a lot out of festivals
I'm guessing let's say like flow events
in the States and you know you clearly
transition to a being a juggler like
when were some of the good things you
got out of flow events start there I
know the flow is a come forward for you
but I mean like what kinds of things did
you decide stepping saying it yes well
what kind of things do you get out of it
or have you have you got my friends and
my network and I wouldn't have met
otherwise inspires me in some kind of
way with a trick or with their
perspective or their outlook or whatever
it is so that's been really positive my
network has grown from those types of
events my skills and teaching teaching
but I was a teacher before I started
juggling and spinning but this gives me
a whole new skill set in teaching people
how to do things with their bodies and
that transfers into my training or into
my work of personal training so that's
been really valuable
communication and I've worked through
organizational roles with AI and
learning how to work in teams and people
with big personalities learning how to
take roles that I might not have chosen
otherwise for the greater good of the
event or because I care about the
success of the event like sitting at the
gate for hours and hours while
everyone's having fun the fire signal or
whatever it is learning how to you know
know your role and and work up to what
you want instead of feeling entitled
something I've learned through so what
are the negative things you've
experienced at these events I don't like
sleeping in a tent
I don't really drink or do drugs so like
sometimes people get a little loose at
those events and I don't really enjoy
being a part of that a whole lot
sometimes there's like in those party
scenes and festival scenes there's kind
of a lack of like consent and lack of
awareness that this person that you're
talking to are communicating what
they're playing with is another human
it's not just this party but I've seen
FAI taken a lot of steps to try to
address that and I'm super proud of you
guys for doing that and happy that
that's something that's happening cuz it
needed to the address hundred percent
Gina I'm not while I'm like two percent
speaking up and doing something and I
know that it's a work in progress and
that there's gonna be missteps and steps
forwards and backwards but like just the
fact that it's being acknowledged and
publicly is huge so is that an issue in
Mexico a lot of catcalling walking
around Mexico maybe I'm just like making
so I'm gonna messed up stereotype of my
people I can stare that constantly
I know they look different and now that
I my hair's not bright colors it's a
little less but I look different than
most people here so I get stared out a
lot and I'm not really sure sometimes
whether it's just because I look
different or because there's that like
but she smell like you're in the public
space different now is it the tattoos or
what's the different people pretty
conservative walk around Mexico City I
figured it might be him there's a lot of
tattoos here people there's more tattoos
on people here than there are in the
States just like the general person but
I have lighter skin I don't like my
accent you know like the way I dressed
the way I carry myself is just different
then thank you I think there's in the
metros and the buses there's a space
just for women and children men aren't
allowed in there and that's because in
those time like where there's people in
the metro there's hella opportunity for
violations in all sorts of ways so
there's also a lot of kidnapping here
like women get kidnapped all the time
here which is crazy but like everyone
thinks Mexico City is a super dangerous
city so like I'm super sensitive to that
like I don't think any City is
inherently dangerous I think that
there's places in the cities that are
dangerous but to discount a whole group
of people or a whole city because you've
heard that is dangerous or because
there's violence there is absolutely
ridiculous so I completely urge people
to step outside their comfort zones and
like be safe about what you do but don't
shut out opportunities or like things
you would do because you have been told
by someone that is dangerous I guess
that's like fire-spinning
so how do you transition like describe
your transition from spinner juggler
juggler flow person to juggler like I'm
just curious because it seemed as if
when I firmage first met you you're more
of a flow goddess type for like Network
dreadlocks yeah Hulu you know you were
kind of wearing those freaking juggling
hats you know like that's sort of one
but how did you transition and what was
a reason for transitioning more and to
say I'm gonna just say a juggler I mean
you described Brian in that process but
what were the reasons for you to
transition
I feel more challenged by toss juggling
and by juggling techniques than I ever
have
with anything with one two or three hoop
manipulation I know that's all a matter
of like what tricks I decide to learn
and what I feel challenged by personally
but the pool of things that I can work
on seems infinitely larger with juggling
and juggling style and techniques I felt
way more inspiration from juggling than
I did from anyone that I was paying
attention to or surrounded by and
spinning world I just saw what they were
doing it was like I want to do that
versus just seeing and you're like oh
that's pretty
I don't know I guess also part of it is
like juggling is more concrete as
something that is respected and is has
more tradition has more history and that
shouldn't discount the spinning or
juggling world or spinning our circuit
or spinning our club their knowledge
aside is finding your flow world but
like no it just feels more legit it
feels more like something that people
respect something that has more the
learning curve that will lead me to
something more concrete something more
like more success there's more respect
there's more dedication there's more
institution behind juggling then there
is brought me there I think I mean like
is it just because spinning is in its
infancy and there hasn't come
manipulators because there's not more
objects I'm just curious what do you
think well I think flow sort of
apparently has that ceiling and I have
my own guess is like for example the
newness
or the the research I think a lot of
Duggars would call it with the props
themselves it's not fully fleshed out in
a way that somebody's done it where
everyone's like whoa you know it hasn't
had that some people say there's never
been an act of many well that's not true
baton twirlers I think are sort of in
there in that Venn diagram of flow but
they're older we like the time oh yeah I
mean we like touch we steal from them
you know I mean looking at staff like
staff takes from page staff take like -
all dragon staff and staff is much
better speech a technique and baton
technique I mean there's very little of
it that is actually been created in the
past 20 years I mean it's probably some
but you know I think I think that it's
too late to change it or what if it's
even worth it this is just my deal but
like I feel like if in the earlier
stages of manipulation if people would
have been less quick to to create their
own separate thing and more mm open or
drawn to connecting themselves to this
thing that already connects exists and
already connects to what you're doing
and already has that research and
already has that kind of institution
like you said with the time spending or
whatever I think that it wouldn't be
such a separate thing and it wouldn't be
even the discussion right now because
like artists exists and has tradition
and has institution and has discipline
practice techniques all of that that we
as manipulators need to do all of that
stuff exactly but I just it just rubs me
the wrong way that we're so intent on
being our own separate thing and I think
that's our detriment that's why people
kind of look down on it
in the middle of the woods or nobody's
watching us and we don't feel judged or
whatever it is because we feel judged
because we're a bunch of hippies in the
forest spinning fire and patchwork or
whatever it is but like like I don't
think that those people deserve less
respect but I feel like there would be
more respect given if there was more
acknowledgement to like where that all
of this comes from and more attention
paid to practice techniques and
dedication mindsets and ways that people
look at that kind of thing
juggling say that right it's more
concrete the skill jumps are clear and
they're a little sharper for example if
you're juggling three balls and you can
just do a regular cascade learning the
reverse cascade is going to be some
effort that is a a level up you know
from where you are that's require a lot
of work so you're not really feeling
like this is why I think people like
clothes or they're spinning or it's
stuff like that it's because you feel
more creative right I mean the reality
of you being creative that's like a
debatable issue but I think when you
step into the world of juggling you see
the next lot like the next thousand
levels above you you're like I can just
toggle 3-ball cascade look at that
person doing all sorts of nutty stuff
just with three balls and each side of
that trick and or throw could be me just
practicing for an extremely long period
of time depending and and granted like
you know it has these like I know what
you want to call them sort of like you
learn this trick you get a bunch more at
the same time like you know you get one
thing a bunch of other things come with
like you learn siteswap a bunch of
things start to come together or
whatever but I think that kind of
prevents you feeling creative I think
slow people like that you know if you I
mean this is like I'm an advocate
because I love juggling a lot and I'm
recognizing chill but if you can light a
thing on fire and feel like a creative
force there's like something that's
pretty pretty humbling interestingly
enough and least in my opinion even now
you know like you know it's weird when
you see someone who spins fire that's
better than you
you can juggle five balls or something
right it's like bizarre is that what
sauce does that person have so I don't
know I just think that there's a lot of
people that just want to feel creative
and want to feel empowered by their
creative thing without looking fully I
completely get that and I think that's
super valuable like me as I think
another reason why I gravitated towards
chuckling is because I I don't feel like
I'm super creative like I feel way more
satisfied or fulfilled drilling a trip
that I see someone else do and then
doing it well I've never seen anyone
else do and I've complete respect and
like that shit's awesome that's why I
love working with McKenzie because that
girl is super creative and looks at
things in a way that I've never would
have thought of but like that's just not
how I'm wired I guess when it comes to
hooping in life so I find my validation
in the drilling and the like oh I can do
this thing that I saw someone else do
and I would love to be able to like I've
never seen anyone else do and I was
stoked on it but I just don't work that
way
as much and I think that's another
reason why I'm super drawn to that side
of it and I respect I totally respect
that need and that feel and that
appreciation for creativity it's awesome
well I mean like what makes you feel
original I don't know this but like
maybe the need to feel creative is not
the right word but what can give you
identity when you're just learning
things potentially much of things you
learn are already set out for you
practicing acrobatics and tricking and I
haven't been new at something in like 8
or 9 years and so I'm like okay I want
to still have fun with this thing and I
want
my disciplined like trick oriented side
of my brain is is getting in the way of
like enjoying the process of learning
again because I want I have this goal in
this trick in mind and I want to do it
instead of thinking of how I can do this
thing that in the process like me and be
have fun and be creative in the process
so that's something that I still chop
like feel challenged by and I don't have
an answer to it so that question really
except for like I would love to be able
to tap into that side of my brain a
little more but I know kind of know how
I work and what is satisfying to me and
then that kind of way and that's why I
feel more satisfied and more fulfilled
through juggling and drilling because
there's a person on the other side of
that that is just the flow guide that
can walk out in front of any crowd and
impress them right I can go out there
and probably I mean I don't know it's
attention to think about where are our
own mental blocks prevent us from seeing
that other side right like the flow
person who's just like really good at
spinning and like just really smooth
between one movement to another people
change speeds whatever like this person
probably recognizes that they are not
fitting into a slot like a pachinko slot
right like they recognize that they're
not they're actually falling into many
but maybe they also desire some
structure in their lives but that
doesn't like that's like a vulnerable
place for that flow person much in the
same way as if you were to get kind of
be out there into age enjoy like the
drilling part in front of other people I
guess and so that compared to would
require some vulnerability yeah I could
definitely see it's like taking a dance
class often brings those feels out like
you take a dance class and you don't
know any like the first one ever it's
just like the weirdest thing of all time
you don't know the people around you you
don't know like some people go in this
class know some of the moves from the
teacher already and you're just like
behind you can't understand it I hadn't
find sometimes that like when I do
something that puts me in those
uncomfort zone like dance is a good
example
I took my dance class once and I wasn't
getting tired like I like the first
three weeks I wouldn't even tire when I
was
and sweat and what is happening
something wrong but I think you know
learning how to work on those like
levels like once later I start getting
tired was like oh I think it's probably
that were breathing right I wasn't
really into it I was just sort of like
rigidly controlling myself and no I
think I think that's entering
dichotomies sorted between flow and
juggling right it sort of seems to
attract you see I think people oscillate
in different ways right I think for
example Kevin Axtell not just throw him
under the bus in this way but he was a
juggler but I think he felt maybe he
felt I don't know maybe he felt that his
creativity was sort of limited by being
a juggler in his ability to express
himself you know and so he's sort of
moved I mean he's always kind of an
expressive guy but I think yeah but but
I mean like he could be more free in my
less of like the constraints of juggling
pedagogy things like that okay let's
talk about that's all about performance
right because if we're talking now we're
kind of moving in that way so
performance is often based I like to
kind of format you would like to is
probably something where you know you
have a bunch of tricks and they're
organized and you know you have a plan I
also enjoy that but do what do you enjoy
performing or do you do still like that
or is it just something you're like have
to do and it's like you know gets you
all nervous or what I think a little bit
of everything you just said
I feel like performing and one of my
goals coming here to Mexico was to be
become to become a better performer I've
always felt really strong and really
confident as a teacher and I know that
I'm good at it but I'm not good at
performing like I am a teaching and I
know that so I came here to work on that
and I've I definitely feel way more
comfortable on the stage I don't get
asked nervous as I used to but I think
if performers tell you that they're not
nervous
I think that's [\h__\h] everyone feels
some sort of pressure when they're
performing you're about to be very
vulnerable in front of people but you
get better at dealing with it
um when I was doing the competitions in
the the IJA and performing with Brian if
I had a bad run I would ruin my week you
know it ruined my next three days like
for whatever it was and now I don't let
that happen as much I try to find the
little gems of places where I can
improve and and don't take everything so
personally um performance is an
extremely vulnerable and personal thing
but when you're putting it out there you
have to look at it more objective and
like how you can entertain people and
not just like be hurt about not landing
a trick or like not having a great run
because it's already out there that
people already have it you have to make
it fun no matter how well you do it and
so that's been that's been a learning
curve here and the performance here is
very different like when I look at my
costume in the music from the
performance I did with McKenzie at ija
I'm like oh that's so [\h__\h] boring
it's so boring because here people are
in glitter sequins and hey at the end of
every trick and it's very traditional
but people know exactly when to clap
that people are entertained through
these accent if you took some of these
acts and put them in to loose some of
these festivals people would hate it but
like my goal for performing here is more
performing for the public and
entertaining the public and not
performing my art for other artists
which is more of what I was doing
in the States so let's talk about this
entitlement thing I want to poke into
this like in what way do you think I
mean the spinning arts community can be
more entitled about their opinions they
are just deal with that it's when they
said that a little bit earlier this is
not a massive generalization but as a
sense people who want to teach people
like in flower community in general but
because of the way that the festivals
are set up in the United States they
bring sometimes
forty instructors and all of those
instructors feel like they deserves
enough money to get them all the way to
festival they feel like they deserve
meals all through the event plus money
on top plus recognition from whatever
just this whole list of things that they
feel like that they want and the way
that festivals are set up in the States
we just don't have the money for that
like that or the community itself
doesn't have money to support events
like that
hooping events are a little different
because it's a different demographic of
older women who tend to have more stable
lifestyles but in our like higher jobs
for any for example most of those people
are in their like 20s or 30s and they're
not rich so the festival itself doesn't
have a whole lot of money to invest in
what each teacher thinks they're worth
also when I look at professional
performers and people who are being
flown out to some of bigger like ija or
like the festival circus festivals in
France or things like that those fools
have been performing professionally for
twenty five years or something like that
they've put so much time and effort they
[\h__\h] deserve a hotel that's nice they
deserve to be fed they deserve money on
top of it but if you've been practicing
spinning fans or double hoops in your
backyard for two and a half years you
don't deserve that in my mind you know
like you deserve respect you deserve
respect and you've put into it but to
come into it and be hurt that that these
organizations who are working on a
shoestring budget are not giving you
enough money to fly you across the
country to teach at their event that
they're gonna sell out no matter what
that kind of mindset it just doesn't sit
right with me and it doesn't like allow
you to grow as an artist or a person
like you have to see where you suck to
get better and you have to see where you
have to put in time to earn respect and
to earn those things that you want and
so you have to act like the you have to
think it till you make it kind of thing
you know like when I see the people who
are giving money for events and are
asked personally to come out to events
and
okay those people put the time in and
like I still feel completely inadequate
when I put myself up against some of
these other people that are coming to
these events and I'm still super
surprised once events asked Kensi and I
to come out and buy his tickets or
whatever it is it's great and I love it
but I'm lost so like really like you
could have these Ukranian hoop jugglers
we've been going to circus full and
performing in seven days a week that's
kind of something that I value more than
someone who puts out an Instagram video
every day or whatever it is there has
70,000 followers like that doesn't mean
anything
that's for your worth as a teacher or as
a circus artist and people tend to
inflate their own sense of self-worth
and feel entitled to these things and
then get angry at the events and looking
for places to place blame like this
interesting conversation the other day
we're sitting down here there's a New
York instructor I'll just drop her name
Clair deluxe and if you've never
probably not just for everybody here I
think you know she's probably one of the
most qualified point instructors I've
ever met I'm bite by 40 right I mean
she's taught probably close to in there
between 20 to 200 people a year for the
past 11 years in weather some flow
manipulation thing or and she's not
getting invited to events right like
there's another part there where it's I
just think that if they were to have the
best teachers we wouldn't have the most
popular people and I think that also and
I think that's true in the circus world
too right we don't necessarily bring out
not saying that people that are good at
circus can't be good teachers or
whatever but I think if you go to a
juggling Festival for example they don't
pay instructors they hope the performers
up a little bit but that's it right
you're not nobody gets paid to teach at
a juggling event but the people who you
pay to coach you that's a going circus
coach those people are expensive right
like if whether you're gonna for
flexibility coach or you're gonna go for
like a juggling coach like a you know
Sergei ignatov workshop or something
like that so I think that there's like
they can kind of see that there's like
this difference there I mean I just
don't understand how
and flow events how money means your
value right and there's an interesting
trade-off there because I think in
juggling communities in the states I
don't think money is really necessarily
in that equation except that we would
pay a lot of money to see somebody like
Michael motion or West Pete and do their
thing you know for five minutes when you
look at even I feel weird even if you
like take Michael motions resume and put
it up to West P dunes like it's still
like this would be the first person to
tell you that you know so like when
people can recognize the time what they
actually are worth or deserved which are
totally things that each person feels
different about but like it's really
important to be humble and to look at
the places the people who are doing the
things you want to do and look at what
they've done to get there and say have I
done that work have I have I put in even
a fraction of what they have to feel
this way you know and it's like we put a
lot of whatever the way they want but
like at the end of the day if it's not
serving you and you're ending up like
being super toxic to the people around
you in the community that you're wanting
to be included in anyway it's just like
super counterproductive well I think
that the community likes to say that it
admire mean by high skill right high
skill tends to be the thing that they
hope to honor in a lot of ways even over
performance or instruction in my opinion
if you're like heist but I think that
high school actually means high
creativity in manipulation which is sort
of the funny part about these flow
events in my opinion I think the more
valued stuff is the skill in which you
manipulate an object not how good and
that is like first and then for some
reason it seems like instruction and
that the very bottom rung is performance
and I think that's just like a trade-off
that I guess the flow events me which is
cool is pushing manipulation
just funny because I think that's also
another reason why juggling and some
people jugular style have never really
fully fit into juggling right because
the manipulation style is something
different you know contact juggling kind
of has that like that there's a lot of
manipulation techniques that are
involved in contacting that aren't
necessarily juggling right now get into
this like confusing conversation or some
of the events a new crop like a freaking
triangle to stick or something right you
know there are Michael motion actually
is probably the best example figuring
out how to manipulate set object in
interesting way not unlimited to the or
Eric Aubry or whatever like the stuff
the shape is irrelevant it's like yeah
Sean great Kennedy or whatever I think
those people in my opinion are actually
the flow are sort of fathers in a lot of
ways you know like here's a fan it looks
like this what the heck do you do with
this fan to make it interesting
right it's or to move it interestingly
in space alright so two more questions
or two more things
so first up tattoos you got show us a
tattoo or two we got some juggling ones
here what's up you got the leg juggling
one like Siamese twin leg so like if you
stand next to each other they're both
there or is it all neat oh hey no
Mackenzie hey Mackenzie how you doing
different than Utah so wait your hair
doesn't match anymore what's gonna
happen with you two so what's that on
your hand
what's his hand stuff is that like
Mexican metal band like Crick and
Dragons and stuff what we got no this is
Cassie so this is funny because Cassie
means almost in Spanish and so whenever
anyone says
they're not so I also not so much right
now but I write graffiti also and so
this is what I write I write Cassie
Cassie which means like almost symbols
on my hands wait did the other hand too
so that's a way are you gonna keep that
free I don't like a slapping hand
[Music]
you know what did you want to noon we'll
talk about the Punisher later never mind
so also hey kendie you in the room still
kennedy dogs for a final scene nice is
nice though your dog is nice but Isis
like chillin right do they get jealous
of each other like Kenzi if you pet goes
too much wises get mad at you so how do
you be a circus to bring can you bring
the it's like Mexico right you can
straight bring this dog to every gig
right bad stereotype but like so how do
you go to gigs and tour with these dogs
do you like trade-off babysitting coming
up for your up soon
we haven't exactly figured out what
we're gonna do for that two weeks so
we're hoping we can just find somebody
to stay in our house and
and take care of our little babies
because that's a challenge
how much is rent there is it how cheap
is it over there I'm sorry like he's
good at are you liking this safe spot
like I mean when we first moved here we
were in the same Colonia the same like
part of town right so we already know
this area our landlord super nice dude
do you see a lot of Americans down there
like Jews hang out with Caitlin ever or
any of those we see Caitlin sometimes
like once every couple months she's
crazy but she's super super fun um
there's certain zones of the city and
parts of the city that you'll go that
you'll be like wait what am I in Mexico
anymore people are speaking hella
English but where we are so much okay
well with that double mcdougal I'm going
to end you both can stay on line for a
minute actually know what before you go
Kenzi what's up with the kendama tell us
are you leaving hoop for Ken Dom are you
gonna turn some Lukas ever here we go
let's talk about it I love having
something in my hands all the time like
sometimes I'm socially awkward and don't
like to talk to people so sometimes I
think I learned that maybe from my
ex-boyfriend I don't know I think it's
super fun so kendama also by I've
noticed while holding a kendama people
don't want to talk to me
hey what is this lame thing this person
is doing he's already late I'm actually
so you two stick on the line Cassie get
back in here
this is sticks out podcast number 12
I've recorded 12 now season 1 has
finished oh nice and so I'm gonna I just
want to say thank you both and Cassie
for being here do you really like the
Giants you just like the logo quick okay
all right and with that thank you so
much guys take care I'm gonna stop this
you to stay on and stop recording